I oh look what the Cat Dragged In good
afternoon
eileene how's your day Dad how was the
day just another day my day was a doozy
it's one of those days you never forget
listen up this young lady is our new
prison
psychologist she may be easy on the eyes
but I assure you she is very
smart I'm Rebecca I
know I don't think I caught your
[Music]
name
oopsie nasty habit that's why I like it
I live a little differently than most
most people they probably scared
you prison is not place for a young lady
you got a big life ahead of you I'm sure
I'm just kind of average I think you
really think you're a normal
person i' bet you brilliant
dreams alen may I confide in you people
are so ashamed of their
desires I have my own
ideas kind
ideas you can never tell anyone do you
understand promise me
okay BL will make you
crazy BL will make you
kill can imagine you with a knife can
you imagine me with a
gun that's very good I yeah I could see
it it's different these
days almost interesting secrets and lies
some things are so
Twisted the only way I ask for some to
die that was a great
trick